Vonzell you transform yourself into
roger ailes mm-hm and again that's not
just a huge physical transformation but
there's parts of this you know because
it famously came out that there was this
toxic culture at Fox and Roger Ailes was
accused of all kinds of inappropriate
behavior and now you're beat you're
becoming that man and there are many
scenes I'm thinking of one scene in
particular with you and Margot Robbie
were you you have to be quite
inappropriate with her and you'd think
is that that must be tough because
you're a nice decent man then you have
to become this person who's doing
something that's so horrifying and
creepy yes yes well except that that was
my role in the film I was playing the
real-life Roger Ailes for sure
but in the movie I was the monster I was
the troll under the bridge in in a fairy
tale and you just have to sort of
embrace that role and of course you're
acting great scenes written by Charles
Randolph our wonderful screenwriter and
acting with Margot who's a fantastic
actress we just attacked it like we knew
what our job was our job was to deeply
unsettle the audience yes it really was
the engine of the entire movie this
scene yeah as much as any scene in the
film and so we went at it and it was
just as troubling to us very disturbing
scene but as soon as it was over we
thought wow we're we great yeah great
free
it's I don't know your job it's just
your job to become that person
interesting an actor yeah and and also
your physical transformation is pretty
stunning it looks like tons of
prosthetics either that or you really
let yourself go no I don't think so yeah
what was involved because your it looks
like you're wearing a fat suit
a big fat suit my second fat suit in a
row after Winston Churchill's fat suit
right I'm gradually it might my closet
is full to overflowing right and I
worked with this great makeup artist
Kazuhiro who ironically enough had done
Gary Oldman's prosthetic makeup for
Winston Churchill okay I had one I'd
worn nothing on the outside of my face
it was all inside right
but Oldman had had this extraordinary
prosthetic makeup and Kazu did that for
me he'd say change your body I mean yeah
it's not just the belly but yeah there's
there's man boobs too well please tell
me that I just didn't embarrass myself
those are prosthetics those are
prosthetic good thank you
the manboobs they put on you they didn't
have time and commercial interestingly
enough I I mean about halfway through I
am Colleen Atwood our our costume
designer we both decided you know he
needs a little bit more up here yeah
so they fashioned these manboobs that
could be attached by velcro yeah yeah
and the discerning film goer might just
perceive that there are some scenes in
which I have manboobs
and somehow I spotted it right away will
I feel pervert I shouldn't really go
public with this because I don't want
that to be the thing that people go to
the movie for on the other hand I may
have sold a few tickets yeah we have
great now we have a photograph of you
you really do become him he's stunning
no it's Wow it is an amazing makeup I
was I was really shocked about something
which is that you are you know one of
our tallest guests and I always register
the fact that there are very few people
I'm six for you come on the show you're
six four and there's there's very few
people in this business that are around
that height now especially actors you
keep playing these roles where you're
playing these famous people like
Churchill and ales who are like five
seven I know how do you do that because
I mean that they can't do anything they
can't remove vertebrae you know but I
didn't note I mean when you were a
Churchill you seemed exactly like
Winston Churchill I didn't I don't
notice it I don't know I just think
small I I used to say I'll never be cast
as anything anyone small right but then
Along Came Lord Farquaad